Any of the questions for coffee animals example the S. A. Wilson's coffee. Why is it so light colored? Is it not roasted? What are the advantages compared to Starbucks dark roast?
Well dark roast coffee, that's my favorite, not Starbucks, but I just like dark roasted dark or the roast.
To me, it has more flavor because you get that roasted flavor. Some people like light roast. Honestly, I think the reason why they like light roast is because they get more of a buzz off of it. Why?
Because the lighter the roast, the more caffeine in it. So this S. A. Wilson's coffee, if you cooked it up in your coffee pot and drank it, you'd probably spit it out and it's rolling away because it's gross.
It's not meant to be drink and drink. It's meant to be used in coffee and it's very, very likely roasted if roasted at all. It's specifically for coffee animals because it has such high caffeine in it. So if you're not going to go with the S. A. Wilson's coffee and hey, I don't have any. I just need to do a coffee.
Don't get a lot of it. I just need to get the right one. You can eat it and try to get it in the right way.
what part of the intestine absorbs this? It's down in the rectum. By only have 11 centimeters
before the tumor will it still absorb probably? You're not really trying to absorb this so
I'll be afraid this is not really the absorption of it's its stimulation. You don't have to absorb
any of it. It's the stimulation of the vagal nerve, but it's in the lower rectal area just
above the ateus. So yeah, you still have, if you only have seven, 11 centimeters before the tumor
will it still absorb properly? Yes, it's not going to be absorbed properly. You're still stimulating
so vagus nerve. Also doing sodium bicarbonate animals, the reason why this person would be good
to do sodium bicarbonate animals. So would everybody do a sodium bicarbonate? No, this person has a
tumor 11 centimeters up. So that's why he's trying to get the sodium bicarbonate baking soda
alkalinity into the tumor. With frankincense and lemongrass oils, while it smells great,
one of the benefits of these essential oils in the animal. These are cancer killers in themselves.
That's why you would do it. I can still only get about eight ounces at most,
a fluid in the animal. I guess that's okay. Yes, that is perfectly okay. That's fun.
Try to hold it five minutes. Sometimes it go a little bit longer. That's great. That's perfect. So
it would great.